I've got some test results back for
coronavirus and it came back positive
yeah and it sucks
idris elba reveals he has tested
positive for corona virus after
experiencing no symptoms I wasn't I
didn't have any symptoms I got tested
because I realized I was exposed to
someone who had also tested positive I
found out last Friday that they were
tested positive a quarantined myself and
got a test immediately got the results
back today as the pandemic continues
more confirmed cases are coming out of
Hollywood
I would love to do the corona test but
there just isn't one here I tried with
two different doctors and I just can't
get one stay safe everyone stay home if
you don't feel good Heidi Klum who was
previously unable to get the test
reveals she and her husband Tom Kaulitz
have now been tested for the virus but
are awaiting results so that's why I've
stayed home to that any other people in
the meantime the couple will stay apart
Tom returned from a tour a few days ago
Heidi wrote to Instagram quote as much
as I want to embrace him and kiss him it
is more important to do the right thing
and not spread further normally I would
go and take photos with everyone I would
you know shake people's hands hug them
you know also when we usually go into
the auditorium I high-five everyone I
take time to talk to everyone and I feel
like you know now is not the time for us
to be clapping hands or shaking hands
too much or kissy Kissy you know
thing you do in my industry all the time
I just feel like we're not living in
that world at the moment so I think we
all for ourselves have to be more
cautious meanwhile Kris Jenner has
tested negative for coronavirus a source
tells ET the 64 year old took the test
after attending Universal Music Group
CEO Lucien Grange's birthday in late
February Grange tested positive for the
virus so Kris who was not displaying any
symptoms wanted to make sure she was
being proactive in getting tested the
first publicly confirmed celeb case was
Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson who ET
confirms have left the Queensland
Australia hospital where they were being
treated after five days they're now
resting at a home in Australia where
they remain in quarantine Hanks revealed
their diagnosis last Wednesday and as
kept fans updated on their recovery
progress other celebs are urging people
to practice social distancing this is
serious you know now's the time to
really think about social distancing
washing your hands beyond that there
were people out there who aren't showing
symptoms and that can easily spread it
hilary duff spoke out after seeing many
heading to bars and restaurants over the
weekend to all you young millennial
tools that keep going out and partying
go home
Arnold Schwarzenegger along with his
mini horse whiskey and mini donkey Lulu
are also urging people to stay home dad
you stay at home because there's a
curfew now especially someone it's like
72 years old
look at this picture nobody okay you got
to get along
[Music]